on l'a senti hier que les autorités
américaines étaient complètement
dépassés george bush lui-même a différé
son retour à washington de quelques
heures tant la menace était forte
le président des états unis a promis des
représailles à l'encontre des auteurs de
ces attentats
et aujourd'hui comme vous le disait
serge kovacs il a reçu en fin de matinée
tous les dirigeants des deux chambres du
congrès devant lesquels il va faire une
nouvelle déclaration officielle gwenaël
le noir 9h36 hier george bush vient
d'apprendre la nouvelle première adresse
d'un président sous le choc à une nation
russie le terrorisme contre notre nation
ne passera pas je vous demande de vous
joindre à moi pour une minute de silence
mégarde vous savez que dieu bénisse les
victimes leurs familles et l'amérique
match merci beaucoup
immédiatement il quitte la floride le
monde entier l'attend à washington
surprise générale l'avion présidentiel
se pose sur une base militaire en
louisiane très loin de la capitale
fédérale
dans une deuxième adresse à la nation il
tient à rassurer malgré tous les
évènements
le gouvernement ne vacille pas notre
armée chez nous et partout dans le monde
et en état d' alerte maximum et nous
avons pris toutes les mesures de
sécurité nécessaires pour que votre
gouvernement continue à travailler
nouveau départ cette fois l'avion
présidentiel a atterri dans le nebraska
sur cette base militaire qui abrite le
commandement stratégique américain
george bush il reste plusieurs heures en
fait les services chargés de sa sécurité
tiennent à vérifier qu'aucun avions
civils ne survolent plus l'espace aérien
avant d'autoriser air force one a
décollé et c'est encadré par des
chasseurs que l'appareil de george bush
relie finalement washington un peu avant
21h heure locale un hélicoptère dépose
le président américain sur la pelouse de
la maison
hanches du bureau ovale il menace j'ai
donné l'ordre pour que toutes mes
ressources en matière de renseignement
et de police il s'attelle à retrouver
les responsables et traduits en justice
nous ne ferons aucune distinction entre
les terroristes qui ont perpétré ces
actions et ceux qui les protègent
aujourd'hui alors que les etats-unis se
réveiller dans un cauchemar
le président américain le visage grave
prononce le mot de guerre les attaques
délibérées et meurtrières qui ont été
menées hier contre notre pays était plus
que des actes de terreur elles étaient
des actes de guerre des actes de guerre
auquel les américains veulent répondre
ce soir
un sondage indique que 90 % d'entre eux
exigé représailles à ces attaques